j'ai eu une vision
des gens brûlé vif
tout était détruit c'était Athéna
c'était à cause d'elle
c'était moi rassure-toi on le laisse pas
faire ça
je t'ai vu sur le ring
c'était forcément toi
et si je te dis que Sienna ici présente
elle a réincarnation de la déesse Athéna
ta destinée à toi est de devenir l'un de
ses chevaliers protecteurs
et ça fait quoi d'être MDS parfois je me
sens étrangère dans mon propre corps
es-tu prêt pour l'entraînement le
chevalier de Pégase se montre courageux
humble et prêt à donner ta vie pour
protéger Athéna
comment tu as réussi à faire ça
la guerre qui nous attend est une
ampleur jamais vue
j'arrêterai à Thénard avant qu'elle nous
détruise
tu crois que j'ai voulu cette vie
son pouvoir nous menace une fois qu'il
saura le contrôlé aucun être vivant ne
lui résistera tu mets ta ceinture ça va
secouer un peu
tu croyais être le seul chevalier